in the last video we had a brief
introduction to amino acids and I
mentioned a few little fun facts or sort
of things that you needed to know about
amino acids when it came to discussing
biochemistry what we're going to do is
we're going to continue our talk of
amino acids and we're going to get into
the different things that you need to
know about each specific amino acid so
things that you should know for
biochemistry about amino acids are their
name of course their name their
structure their three-letter
abbreviation or code their one letter
abbreviation and sort of important
characteristics other important
characteristics that are specific to
different amino acid so I'll put here
important characteristics or or fun
facts ok so that's just a few things
that we should know about each amino
acid and in this video in particular I
want to talk about the nonpolar amino
acids okay so of which I mentioned there
were 20 amino acids in the last video
that's what I mentioned and I talked
about how given the V the structure of
an amino acid the Fischer projection
looks like this with the carboxyl group
up here it's negatively charged this is
of course at a pH of 7 right or a
neutral pH the amino group here on the
Left protonated carboxyl group or fret
dimension is deprotonated and of course
here this R group or the sidechain and
this is what actually is different
between each amino acid these three
things here these three substituents are
all constant between all twenty amino
acids but there are 20 different R
groups or side chains that makes each
ask unique so in this one we're going to
talk about the nonpolar amino acids now
how many of them are there how many
non-polar ones well they're 20 total but
nonpolar there are nine of them okay so
in this video what I wanted to do
essentially was to draw the diny
different nonpolar amino acids so you
can know their names their structures
their abbreviations and important little
things to keep in mind about each one so
let's just get right into it so the
first one I'm going to draw is looks
like this okay and the R group is just
an H if you recall that was glycine
right so this amino acid here is glycine
three-letter code for glycine is GL Y
and the one letter code is just G okay
so we need to know the name the
three-letter abbreviation in the one
letter abbreviation so if someone if you
know maybe a professor or a teacher
TA whatever it is ask you to draw a
glycine they might not tell you ask
Allah you know they might not ask you
just draw a glycine and they might say
draw the amino acid abbreviated as GL y
or draw the amino acid G and as far as
why do we have these little
abbreviations I mean in science
oftentimes things get really complicated
so shortening things down is helpful so
you need to be familiar with the idea
that this structure goes with this name
and these two different abbreviations
okay now what there's a something
specific that I mentioned about glycine
when we went over in the last video and
I mentioned that it was not chiral right
and the reason why is because it has it
doesn't have four different substituents
it's our group is simply an H and in
order to be chiral you have to have four
different substituents on the on the
carbon so glycine is unique in that it
can't be in the L form or D phone D form
oh by the way all the amino acids I'll
be drawing will be
drawn in vol 4 right so let me just note
that here so this is of course elf form
and if you're unfamiliar as to what that
is if you encourage you to look at the
past video ok so the first one is by
scene okay the next one now actually
henceforth what I'll be doing is instead
of drawing out the carboxyl group the
amino group in the H I want you to
understand that I'm just going to not
draw those groups just for simplicity
sake I'm just ence for some just going
to draw the R group just to just save
time ok I don't want you to have to
watch out an hour-long video so the next
our group is simply just a methyl group
now this amino acid is called alanine
it's three-letter code is ala and it's
one letter code is a often you'll find
that the amino acid three-letter
abbreviation is just the first three
letters of the actual name and likewise
with the one letter abbreviations off
it's often just the first letter that
isn't always the case as well no because
there are some amino acids that sort of
you know their names start with the same
letter so that can't be the case every
time are there any particular fun facts
about alanine that you should be
familiar with well not really it just
has that methyl group nothing too
exciting about alanine and again keep in
mind that the carboxyl group is still
supposed to drawn here the H is supposed
to be drawn here and the amino group is
still here I'm just keep keeping it out
of there or meeting it just for
simplicity sake okay this next one I'm
going to draw here is uh looks like this
so we have attached to the alpha carbon
is a CH and then there's a methyl group
here and a methyl group here now this
amino acid is called valine valine
three-letter code is v al and it's one
letter code is V now
crazy by baling in terms of fun facts
but what I want you to keep I want you
to notice is that you can remember
Balian structure by kind of remembering
the idea that it looks kind of like a V
right it's an upside-down V here so that
can just kind of keeping that in mind
can help you remember the structure of
baleen okay
so um the next one I want to draw looks
like this okay so we have CH 2 CH 2 s
and CH 3 this now this amino acid its
name is Mathias I thio mean three-letter
code is M et one letter code is M okay
now this one's a little bit different
and and there are a few fun facts I want
you to keep in mind about my signing now
myth finding is is you might recognize
that name and the reason why is if you
took an earlier biology course you might
remember that when we're talking about
translation the start codon by the start
codon in translation is Aug right which
codes for the first amino acid is
methane right so it is the first amino
acid in many many proteins so when
translation occurs the first amino acid
implemented is methane
so it's a fun fact that you should keep
in mind another one another fun fact
about it is that it's one of two amino
acids that are sulfur containing so in
the last video I mentioned a sort of my
abbreviation for amino acid but finding
is one of the one of two amino acids
that has a sulfur
okay so it's one of two amino acids
containing sulfur again so that's just
another thing to keep in mind
just a reminder these ends here
they still look exactly like like this
right I'm just not drawing them to save
time and probably space as well okay so
those are the fun facts I want you to
keep in mind about my finding so that's
four of the nine amino acids so far the
next one looks like this okay now this
one looks like this as a ch2 attached to
a CH and then that CH is attached to do
different methyl groups now this amino
acid is called leucine leucine it's
three-letter code is Leu one letter code
is L so far these three letter codes and
one letter codes have been pretty
self-explanatory and they pretty much
are further the nonpolar amino acids
leucine if you notice it looks pretty
much like veiling the only difference
right the only difference between them
is that leucine has this this you know
the ch2 before it actually splits off
into this V shape here so if you kind of
keep in mind that valine and leucine
have a very very similar structure you
know obviously that can help you write
that can help you remember these
structures and then whatnot
okay so that is that is leucine the next
one I'd like to draw looks like this
okay this next one looks like this we
have a CH here then we have a ch3 just
the methyl group and then here we have
ch2 and then off of that as a ch3 okay
so this there's a CH here much like in
the leucine and valine and that CH has a
methyl group and then not just two
different methyl groups has a methyl
group and an ethyl group here so leucine
has this same a number of carbons notice
this has one two three four carbons
right this has one two three four
carbons in the sidechain and there are
actually structural isomers and so this
this amino acid here is called ISO
leucine okay now this is where the
three-letter codes get a little bit
trickier it's not it's not ISO the
three-letter code it's actually I L II
so let me actually make that a little
bit more specific i LP and it's one
letter code is i okay so in this K this
is one of those cases in which the three
letter code is not the first three
letters of the name of the amino acid so
there is a fun fact that you should keep
in mind about about isoleucine first of
all that it's a structural isomer of
leucine okay oops oh blues of leucine
excuse me
another thing is that it's an amino acid
that actually has two chiral centers it
has two chiral centers what do I move
that and what do I mean by that now
notice glycine doesn't have a chiral
Center but all these other amino acid
there alpha carbon right has four
different substituents now isoleucine
also has that alpha carbon right that is
chiral but now this carbon here also has
four different attachments to it this
this whole chain here with the amino
group the carboxyl group in the H that
are not drawn but are implied as I
mentioned before the the hydrogen and
this methyl group and this ethyl group
so it has four different substituents on
this carbon so this has two different
chiral centers in this amino acid so
that's also something to to bear in mind
when when thinking about isoleucine okay
so let's
make some more space now that's a what
is that that's one two three four five
six of the of the nine nonpolar amino
acids let me scroll down a little bit
and draw these next few these next three
right so this next one looks like this
and this one's a little bit weird so I'm
actually going to draw the D what's it
called the carboxyl and amino groups so
I didn't draw them earlier but now I'm
going to draw them a little bit
differently so this one looks like this
I am NOT like freaked you out right now
but these are just carbons here so this
is a ch2 this is a ch2 this is a ch2 and
this here is the amino group now
what's crazy about this amino acid is
that the R group actually comes back and
connects to the amino group so notice in
the other amino acids I drew the amino
groups as nh3 plus is right so the N has
four bonds to it right the the bonds of
the alpha carbon end to these three
different hydrogen so that's four total
bonds in this case this this n also
still has four bonds but notice now when
it's protonated it's going to have only
two ages attached to it it'll still
carry that plus charge right button
it'll only have two hydrogen's as
opposed to as opposed to three because
now it has two bonds to carbon as
opposed to the other amino acids we just
have just has one so this one's kind of
crazy a little bit a little bit weird
this one's actually called prolene so
proteins three-letter code is PR o and
it's one letter code is one so there's
obviously fun facts about prolene
because it's so weird right so prolene
we say that it's alpha amino group is
secondary is secondary
now secondary just implies that the N in
the amino group is bound to two carbons
right so it's about at this carbon the
alpha carbon
this other carbon here this part of the
sidechain okay so all other amino acids
there there alpha amino groups are
primary is only bound to one carbon so
in addition that you can imagine that Oh
actually excuse me we're in the future
we'll be talking about how you know how
these amino acids sort of connect to
form long polypeptide chains and
eventually proteins and they're going to
be connected at the mean of groups and
carboxyl groups in long long chains and
again we'll talk about that later I
don't want to confuse you too much but
imagine if an other amino acid is
connected from here to here right it's
car box it's another amino acids
carboxyl group is connected to this
amino group on prolene now you can
imagine the steric hindrance associated
here with all this all you know given
that the fact of the R group is attached
to the the Alpha amino group so there's
actually no free rotation about that
group and what ends up happening is that
because of steric hindrance this amino
acid when it's implemented in proteins
it creates kinks in protein structure
creates kinks or bends in protein
structure and that's simply due to
steric hindrance now if you remember
from organic chemistry steric hindrance
or is just the whole idea that you know
atoms take up some sort of space and if
they come into contact with other atoms
they're going to bump and things like
that so atoms want their space electrons
want their space that electrons want to
be you know sort of away from other
electrons those like charges repel so
this this um you know this clutter here
around the amino group you know causes a
steric hindrance for anything else it's
going to be bound to it so what ends up
happening is that this amino acid sort
of bends away because of that that's
steric hindrance okay so so prolene is a
little bit unusual in that sense
okay so again those fun facts are things
to bear in mind
about prolene okay so so far that's
seven of the of the nine amino acids of
the nine of the nine nonpolar amino
acids to be specific so let's draw the
last two the last two the first one
looks like this okay now when I draw
here is this now these have rings so
they're already kind of crazy this one
this here these are double bonds within
the rings this has a nitrogen here
attached to a hydrogen and the rest of
these are just carbon hydrogen bonds
this amino acid is called tryptophan
tryptophan and it's three-letter code is
TRP so again that's a little bit unusual
in that it's not the first three but it
still sort of makes sense if you sell
TRP you would probably think tryptophan
the the one letter code for tryptophan
is not actually T it's W and the reason
why is because there's other amino acids
that start with the letter T and we'll
get to that in a future video but in
tryptophan it's actually W that's kind
of weird but maybe this will help if you
look at the way this thing is drawn if
you look at it from the right kind of
have these if you just follow the bonds
you kind of got this shape going on over
here that's actually a W if you tilt
your head to the left
so tryptophan if you want to remember
it's one letter code if you remember its
structure you can kind of just it can
help you remember the one letter code so
things to keep in mind about tryptophan
is that now notice all these are I
talked about all these different amino
acids so far being non polar and
nonpolar is sort of synonymous with
hydrophobic tryptophan right has the
sentient this nitrogen here so it's
a little bit less it's a little bit less
hydrophobic or nonpolar then the the
rest of the nonpolar amino acids it's a
little bit less hydrophobic than other
nonpolar amino acids okay and that's
because of this nitrogen here this
nitrogen has is pretty electronegative
but relatively the overall structure all
these carbons and hydrogen's essentially
end up yielding this or grouping to be
an nonpolar and hydrophobic but it's a
little bit less like I said a little bit
less hydrophobic than all these other
groups because it actually contains a
somewhat electronegative atom now
another thing to keep in mind is that
this ring structure here is is called an
indole ring an indole structure okay and
I'll note that here as well
oops into the structure and it's also an
aromatic has an aromatic sidechain if
you remember back to organic chemistry
until you often talked about benzene
being the classic aromatic structure
this entire in dual structure is
aromatic so this is has an aromatic
sidechain or R group okay so that's
enough about tryptophan but again that
that little W shape can help you
remember the one letter code of V amino
acid tryptophan so that was eight that's
eight out of nine last one looks like
this and just to seal the deal I might
as well draw the carboxyl group the
hydrogen in the amino group on this one
just as a reminder that all of those
that I've drawn should have had those
but I wanted to save time it's already
been what 21 minutes so far so this one
looks like this
this amino acid so it has a ch2 and then
this benzene ring right so what this one
is called is actually called
phenylalanine phenyl alanine so it's
three letter code is Phe with one letter
code is F right because P has already
been taken by prolene so what makes
sense kind of phenylalanine that has the
F sound so that shouldn't be too tough
to remember the fun fact about this one
is that it's also as an aromatic side
chain right that if you remember back to
organic chemistry a benzene rings as a
substituent is usually considered a
phenol so this is a phenol well what
does the alanine come from well if we
scroll back up really briefly but notice
that alanine was just a methyl group
well phenylalanine is just has a phenyl
group attached to the alanine right this
methyl group just has it just has a
phenyl attached to it so again that can
help you remember if you're know alanine
and you know what a phenyl group is then
phenylalanine shouldn't be too tough to
remember so this also has an aromatic R
group as well like tryptophan okay one
thing I wanted to mention was that the
idea of aliphatic side chains and
actually scroll back up and mention that
so anything any structure that has you
know just carbons and hydrogen's and no
rings would be considered an aliphatic
side chain so let me note that up here
in red okay so anything that's aliphatic
simply means carbons and hydrogen's
right in the side chain with no rings
so no alanine valine would be considered
to have aliphatic side chains okay so
that's pretty much it for the amino
acids that are nonpolar those are their
names their structure
they're three-letter abbreviations or
one letter abbreviations important
characteristics for a few of them that
you should bear in mind and the little
tricks here and there that can help you
remember them and that's pretty much it
and keep in mind that all of these that
I've drawn here are the predominant
forms at a pH of seven all of these
groups all of these are groups are non
ionizable which means that you can't
turn them into ions right we'll get into
the in the next video we'll talk about
polar amino acids and how they sort of
work so these ones are all the non polar
ones and I hope that was a helpful video
see you next time